we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk
[Music]
man these pretzels are making me thirsty
[Laughter]
keep it in are we rolling all right we
got that let's do it
all right hey everybody here we are we
might be drunk
episode 22 i think oh
all right good year yes 22 baby
skidoo which is a new york term skadoo
23 skadoo i don't know that's uh
because on 23rd street the wind would
blow women's skirts up
they called it 23 skidoo something like
that i'm off but give it a goog matt
this year this is the year the wind gets
me tooed
here's a clip of what it did to marilyn
monroe that's true yeah
that was uh not consensual hit me today
we're doing manhattan's little fireside
chat is that what it's called
uh fireside cocktail fireside cocktails
and we're gonna have a chat
i like i like fireside chat there's
something nice about this yeah
let's go we still need a name for our
for a rye
yeah what what we came close on
something those you following
we're making our own rye yes so
send us some names in hey hey cheers
little day drinking
hey it is sunny out folks
this is a manhattan yeah that's the
thing about our schedule sometimes we
got a day drink to make this work we're
both in the road again pretty hard
yeah oh that's not bad not bad good job
fireside but yeah
what was i saying you were saying we
need a name for a ride oh yeah we've
come up with
call back i like call back i like call
back and then
i also like cockfight cockfight's fun
yeah
it's also fun like us uh uh get a little
[ __ ] with
two gloves on it yes and a cigarette in
its mouth
like a dick or a rooster rooster okay
yeah you can do the dick
i don't know if you want a dick on a
bottle yeah i don't think i think that's
jarring if you're in a liquor store and
you're like
makers knob creek it's a little
aggressive yeah give me the dong
although knob creek sounds like a dick
yeah
might not it does bullet makes you think
of a dick yeah that's true it's a bullet
but it's like a phallic
right remember the washington bullets
were you around for that of course
they changed it because the owner knew
someone who got shot which is like such
a dumb
it's like oh you discovered that bullets
hurt people
that's a good realization to make yeah
but i mean lions hurt people
i think it was more the crime aspect
yeah but i think it hit the owner
personally also i'm sorry bullets is a
cooler name than the wizards
bullets is great and then you got grand
wizards that's true so now we're off on
this territory
huh yeah was it was it dimitri
martin used to have a joke where it was
like i'd rather see the actual things
fight than the teams
greg fitzsimmons fitzsimmons yeah yeah
somebody stole that from him but that's
a whole another pod
oh yeah we won't go to greg i'll tell
you after but yeah he's got a he's got a
whole beef about it
but uh yeah wizards is boring that's
like harry potter
magic the gathering get out of here come
on it's nerdy this is sports
yes exactly what's the next the warlocks
the witches yeah the elves the lion the
witch and the wardrobes
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah exactly never read
it yeah i think i don't think i've read
it either
i'm still mad about the utah jazz yeah
where has less jazz than utah
that was in the opening of baseball oh
underrated movie yeah
they say the the lakers moved to los
angeles where there are no lakes
right the uh from minneapolis the uh and
the uh
and the jazz moved to utah where they
don't allow music that was the whole
thing
in the intro that's a very underrated
movie
great comedy is that that first of all
zucker i think directed it and then the
guys uh trey and matt wrote it
i met zucker on uh who wrote naked gun
by the way
and he vote airplane too right yes he's
written
the best slapstick i met him i thought
we'd hit it off a little better i met
him on the impractical joker's
cruise oh wow he was just hanging out
what
is he a joker fan i think he's a fan of
the jokers i think they also just have
made
they're so famous they've just made
weird friendships
yeah i get that like that when i was on
the joker's cruise the
it was doug stanhope having a
conversation with um
joey fatone of backstreet boy or in sync
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] am i
watching that's like a weird dream yeah
yeah it was like one of those lunesta
commercials i'm like there's a gopher
talking to lincoln and like in the
kitchen you're just sleeping you're like
it was undressed thompson was there
and frank sinatra right right yeah yeah
exactly it was uh
what's that guy's name ron perlman
talking to
uh you know timberlake yeah brutal but
yeah fun trip
it was fun that was cruises stressed me
out that one of the best parts of that
cruise was
i'm on the boat with a great crew of
comics it was like rich foss was on tim
dylan oh nice
uh papa's kreisher yeah it was a crew
and uh
yamaneika it was a fun group of people
and i remember
after one of the shows some were tough
you know it's a boat and we're waiting
by the door and this woman walks up to
me and she goes
you were our favorite right in front of
rich voss and he turns and goes oh yeah
well your other friends are prettier
than you
everyone laughed except for them avi but
like voss has
he's had that loaded for 35 years of
course of course what did quinn say voss
is the king of the counter punch
he really is you can't beat him in
anything
he got me once on o a i mean i i was
crushed for like a week i had to hide it
but
i was zinging him and i felt like i got
the best of him
and there was some guest on the show
like some author or some nerd guy
and then he goes you like comedy and the
guy goes yeah sure he goes you like mark
norman he goes never
heard of him and vos has stared at me
and i was like
he made the other guy zing me that was
how good he is damn
yeah it crushed me that's like magneto
like just getting the device and
throwing it at you exactly exactly yeah
he got me once
i was like 21 years old and i did the
friars club roast of omarosa
and i bombed so hard like crushingly
hard
voss goes on after me and bombs a joke
and goes you guys better laugh or i'm
bringing sam back
up the room explodes it was
crushing yeah i did a jewish gig in long
island
at a like a country club i was eating my
ass i ate my ass for like a half hour
kierson went up killed and then voss
went up and killed even harder i was
like
i at first i was like this crowd sucks
they're a bunch of stuffy whatever
he killed he just sat on the stool and
made fun of the guy in the front row
he happened to be like the mayor of the
club killed
he's so quick i know i know i try to do
material i'm like uber huh
and they're like nah we don't take uber
we have a driver yeah we're like we
don't you're like we're observational
comics you don't get what we do here and
they're just like just [ __ ] make fun
of the room
exactly yeah that's all they wanted they
wanted racist jokes
and making fun of the rich guy in the
front
that's a great combo yeah i know i know
i wish i would have known that i have
both of those things but
i wasn't ready you were you were in
tacoma right over there yes
how was it great weekend seven shows
sold out at capacity but uh
just like still a sellout man they're
still buying tickets a lot of the time
they comp those
those rooms that's those are it's your
people yes exactly
uh it was all white no it's my people
it's a stinky town
it is it smells weird yeah yeah it's
like a port town with like factories
it's very old school it's blue collar
yeah but it's blue collar meets pacific
northwest so it's pretty and the
scenery's unbelievable and it's actually
a good
balance it is yeah it works there's
hiking
and there's like you know misogyny it's
got it all
but uh great town great club just and i
did that la run with all those podcasts
so it was like
it was nice to go to tacoma and just go
to the woods
i had a hike you know i am he drink
coffee on a picnic table staring at the
the sea good times i remember i haven't
been there in a bit but i remember
last time i was there there's a rec
center which i love a rec center on the
road i don't know like
with coven now i don't know if it's the
same but like you just go in it's like a
five dollar day pass
yeah just play hoops you can go swimming
if you want
is that a y yeah same thing yeah yeah
but uh yeah i was playing with these
kids and they're all these like white
dudes with earrings
pacific northwest it's like this is like
this is the toughest we got yeah
they were [ __ ] great oh really yeah
it sucked i was like i was not getting
the ball i was like god damn it i got to
just like hustle and get rebounds
yeah that area set washington portland
oregon area is so weird that mount
rainier just stares at you
it was just outside my hotel looking at
me like an old man with a boner just
right in my right at my uh hotel window
i would just get up every day and have
coffee and stare at it
great time it's a it's a good little
city and they got those steep hills
there you got to walk up the hill to get
to the club it's like a black diamond
trying to get to the club every night
it's crazy
it's tough yeah and but the crowds were
on fire crowds were great they get a
little sloppy over there but
it's a fun sloppy the crowd's like a
like a stallion and you got to ride it
you know
but uh they said they buy more merch
there than anywhere i sold out all my
shirts and
i sold a good amount of shirts i might
have overdone it just with the it was
like five shows i
first time i sold shirts i think i sold
like i wanna say like 70 something
that's great for first time yeah i was
like yeah i don't have a j i think i
need a joke about
don't have one either i think it might
help that might help i was in cleveland
which dude i love cleveland
cleveland is so underrated i always say
it's the best city in ohio
suck it cincy and you're [ __ ] chilly
that's that's it's just like not
creative yeah yeah spaghetti with chili
it's kind of like
you like you you forgot you had
ingredients and you're like i'll whip
this together
right right it's like a high guy on
chopped
it's a high guy in job but it's also
like okay you did that once
you don't just own it and make it your
thing yes
exactly that's a good point skyline
chili
it's just shitty pasta right yeah shitty
pasta with
you know meat sauce i like chili
i like and i like chili is like my do
you make chili
no i should i'm not a fireman but uh i
should
have you made chili i make it all the
time that's one of my
pandemic i did it constantly because it
was like it was beginning the pandemic
was like a good
it's just a good food at last you put in
the freezer it's uh
it's fun to make you really just all you
have to do is keep dumping ingredients
until it tastes the way you like it's
for a novice cook like myself it's
perfect
interesting i've never thought to me i
love it i get it i get it wendy's
yeah it's chilly i get some you can make
it pretty healthy too you get like some
turkey meat you get a bunch of veggies
some hot peppers i throw some sauce up
in that [ __ ]
i make it i make it nice and spicy some
hot sauce
i uh i'm so impressed i go black and
pinto beans i mix it you would love it
this is my kind of meal i like hearty i
like comforty the best and dude i got
this is i mean it's not like i came up
with this but this is a nice little
touch if you want to stay keep it
healthy and it tastes delicious
substitute for sour cream greek yogurt
tastes great
tastes great bunch of cheese some
avocado on there
uh squeeze some tostitos drop it on got
yourself a [ __ ] hearty little meal oh
i'm hearty holy [ __ ] that is very
impressive
i love it yeah man you're like a you're
like an old detective at home you're
drinking whiskey making chili
like i picked you in a trench coat with
boxers oh my god that's great
yeah i'm gonna try that because uh well
what's the base is it a tomato base
you could do that i like what i like to
do there's a lot of way i mean you can
kind of get creative with it i like to
just
uh i dump a bunch of beans i do a few
cans of beans
i try to strain it a little so it's not
too watery a bunch of beans
i probably go like a little more black
than pinto but i mix it up
dump some salsa in there i do a bunch of
veggies
oh man i'm on board hot peppers bell
peppers
uh and then you gotta get that meat in
there yeah man and you just gotta have a
big pot
yeah big pot stir it it's fine you kind
of let it go you can kind of like let it
simmer and just like watch tv or
something or work on something
it's a fun thing to do because you just
keep adding stuff i like stuff that you
just keep adding and you're like
oh i can just keep as long as you don't
go too hard with the spice
you keep doing it gradually you get it
to the right place i [ __ ] love it
i'm i'm very impressed and i'm excited i
gotta come over come over let's do a
let's do a chili day
cause see i'm the guy at the restaurant
who gets the soup
so you ever go to a restaurant cause i
get the soup almost every time and
they're always surprised cause no one
buys soup
at a restaurant you're the biggest soup
guy i've ever met i love soup i like a
chowder a bisque a chili
uh uh a broth a gumbo you name it
you ever go to the soup nazi in uh new
york i did i wasn't impressed
it was fine it's very expensive way it
was like nine dollars for a cup
and then it was just you get a banana
and i'm like what what's with the banana
yeah they give you a banana
oh i didn't get a banana they always
give you a banana huh it's like
what are you my [ __ ] mom packing me
for soccer practice yeah banana how
about a piece of bread you psycho
i think it bread too oh okay banana the
lobster bisque is pretty good there it's
pretty good it's pretty good but i
waited in line
it was a cold day it was nine dollars i
i went there from
like visiting from new orleans because
it was like still
i don't know 1999 so the soup nazi was
still hot
but uh yeah i haven't gone back since
but even as a tourist i was like
he was pissed i think that they called
him the soup nazi he sued and won
wow yeah they settled out of court but
he he did all right
soup nazi yeah you couldn't you probably
couldn't do that now
yeah probably not not at least not nbc
yeah that's true i mean they went hard
they had like a masturbation
episode they had a date rape but they
don't say they always say things like
master of your domain they kept it very
like even the way letterman would do a
sex joke it was very much like a wink
and a nod to the crib
right right look at look at the office
that's like 10 years ago
oh [ __ ] joke black joke lego rape
jokes it's like
this is crazy this is nbc dude it's
they've pulled it in
more quickly than any 10 years i think
of any
time uh network i think so yeah i think
you're right well i think with the
internet and everything everything has
been sped up so we've always kind of
progressed as a society but it's just
been
amplified and sped up because of the
internet because you can talk
more yeah and more things like this
happened on this you're like all right
sorry let me do my apology tour
i [ __ ] up i loved your tweet the other
day about uh
how you're like say you're sorry okay
i'm sorry and you're like you didn't
mean that why did it mean the joke
oh yeah exactly that's that's comedy in
a nutshell folks
i i pinned it down this happened to me
in tacoma such as comedy it's like any
it's like
people demanding apologies yeah like
sometimes we just say [ __ ] like we speak
so much
right that we're gonna misstep sometimes
of course yeah totally and just because
you're upset by it i'm not it might not
be so i don't know where you're at we
have different lines
it's funny it's like man who's the best
basketball player of all time michael
jordan
he missed shots ah good point it's like
pulling him aside why'd you miss that
shot
cause i don't make every shot i take yes
exactly
i'm trying here i have to i have to make
a shot to see if it'll land
that's the only way to know you can't
ride in your house you can ride at your
house but you still never know unless
you test it
you know what's interesting ari said
this to me ari shafir once said this to
me like he's like the reason i never
tweet
is because it's like he's like you know
what the comedy seller when you go
downstairs and there's someone who's not
a part of the show but they have to go
downstairs to use the bathroom oh
yeah that's what twitter is to me wow
that's great people i think it's a great
observation it's people
walking in who aren't a part of the show
and now they're upset
like what did you say that's great those
are the people because twitter you get
retweets so it's like new audience
that's how you build a baseball yeah
right but a lot of those people were
like how dare you and you're like
you don't get that i'm being sarcastic
right now yeah yeah this is a performer
this is a comedy show this is all
meant to get a laugh that's it i'm not a
politician i'm not trying to change the
world
just trying to be a [ __ ] i mean a
fart can be funny but if somebody walks
into your fart cloud
you're an [ __ ] you know but it was
just for humor for yucks
yeah it was a mel brooks quote it was a
uh comedy
is uh a tragedy is when i get a paper
cut comedy is when you fall off a cliff
[Laughter]
i'm paraphrasing so i might be wrong on
that sounds pretty good sounds right uh
charlie chaplin said uh he was talking
to some guy about comedy and this is
like the best
comedy advice i've ever heard somebody's
like all right he's like okay
you got a guy on the street make that
funny and the guy goes okay
okay he's walking down the street and he
falls in a manhole
how funny is that charlie chapman's like
hold on let me make it funny
guys walking towards a manhole you think
he's about to fall in
gets hit by a car that's comedy and i'm
like oh
that's great because you got to be one
step ahead that's not just comedy that's
life oh there you go
that's like you you spend your whole
life worrying about one thing another
thing [ __ ] you
yeah so true so true like sam kinnison
died on the highway by another drunk
driver
this is the biggest coked up alcoholic
you know womanizer
fat [ __ ] you know crazy rockstar
comedian
t-boned by a drunk driver shouts out to
carla beau by the way r.i.p carl above
tr sam kinnison's opener i never met him
but i
i respected him a lot i never did either
but everybody loved him and uh had
great things to say and said he murdered
yeah so man kennison that is and
yeah you're right he [ __ ] he died
at the hands it's [ __ ] crazy yeah so
god damn it live
folks i think also coven makes me think
of this [ __ ] too where you're like
it's crazy the things we worry about and
then covet happens
this is a worry no one would have
predicted fine some people are like a
pandemics coming some people say that
but for the most part
this was not the thing the average
person was worried about
and then this happens and you're like
man this wiped out like
not only so many people but so many
businesses you know i know i know so
true and nobody saw it coming yo you got
the psycho
and the weirdo with the bunker who's got
eight cans of uh
tuna fish and costco black beans and
garbanzo beans all day long but
nobody saw this [ __ ] tuna fish you got
me [ __ ] now you got me jonesing for
something oh sam hasn't eaten today for
the
i haven't eaten we got some we got some
peanut butter pretzels
so i could soak up some of this booze
but i came i came without eating i
[ __ ] up
yeah well we got a free meal at the city
winery oh hell yeah
i based my whole life around free meals
we do i plan them i play my whole
day so do i like i'm like okay i'll be
at the club at 7 30. it's a good meal
too they got good food
great food in cleveland at that club and
hilarity's check it out
dude i by the way i just quick shout out
to hilarities in cleveland if you live
in cleveland
go to hilarity it's it's it is a
national staple i don't i think we might
even forgotten to mention is one of the
best clubs in a couple weeks
oh yeah because we we just we just as
sometimes we forget but dude that is
that's like a top five club in the
country it's insane when you go to that
club and then you go to another club a
week later
syracuse you're like what the [ __ ] is
going on you could have this but you
have this
i remember i got in trouble with
syracuse once uh
my agent at the time said what did you
do you walked like 30 people and i was
like uh my act
what do you mean what did i do oh [ __ ]
all you see yeah right
i bombed it's wow that's a bomb i've
never walked 30 on a bomb
i yeah you know cues for you it's tough
it's in a mall
it's syracuse you got a lot against you
there you really do
it's freezing cold nobody's happy they
should be happy at the show i know
we're not cold in the showroom bring the
[ __ ] energy guys
please please i think it's a lot of
paper tickets for us
or it used to be me yeah well dude that
was the thing people don't get like
papered for those of you that don't know
what you're talking about it's free
tickets
yeah guess what you have no investment
in a free show no one gives a [ __ ]
no one gives a [ __ ] and they're they're
kind of like you
you you're lucky i'm here i drove here i
parked the car
i'm buying two drinks bring it [ __ ]
like you make me laugh instead of like
hey let's have a good night that's how
we're feeling like
i'm gonna go i got some great jokes you
got some laughs here we go but they're
like
now you gotta pull it out of me that's a
good night but i think that's the
general
public for the most part probably
because you think about things
it's been it's harder than ever to be an
entertainer now and i think we were
always guys that like needed laughs
immediately
yeah but think about how people consume
content now it's like
an algorithm based on [ __ ] you already
like so we're competing with that so we
sneak in people like [ __ ] this guy i
[ __ ] hate this guy
because it people's time is more
valuable than ever
right they're like mad that you
infringed upon their time
yeah especially when they could just be
sitting at home with streaming tv
they got their phone in their hand they
got grubhub at the door i mean
everything is right there and then now
now we're like hey you got to listen for
a minute to laugh at this you got to
hear the setup you got to pay attention
so we're asking a lot now more than ever
we're asking a lot but also
they're given the least that they've
ever given like we might be asking a lot
but
they're getting the most free content
that's ever been available ever
true and they've never been more
critical i know but that's uh
that's human nature i think the more you
get we're gonna
hey look who showed up the more you give
the more you want that's just how people
are you know like
no one ever goes hey this is great we
have all this stuff now they go what's
next
you know it's like louie's joke about
the uh the internet on the plane
the internet we have internet on a plane
now it went out for one second
what the [ __ ] and that's just kind of
how people work yeah
no you're right we want it right when we
get it we want it to work perfectly
every time and never go backwards
i mean i relate to that bit it sucks
when a bit of a comedian you love
where you're like [ __ ] i do that like
yeah like i definitely like
man wi-fi my hotel goes out i'm like
come on
i know i know we go to length to have
things set up the way we like and we
travel so much when anything goes wrong
it's it's pretty disappointing i try to
check myself a little more
i'll be honest my recommendation for
this week
to go into it therapy ah
interesting it's not a movie it's not a
book i went back into therapy
today and holy should i need it
really i've been holding some [ __ ] down
oh yeah
it was it's gonna make me i think it's
gonna make me a better human being
because i took time off and i
i swear to god i tried to do a bit about
this but
when i i quit therapy all the time and
whenever i quit he looks at me like i'm
an athlete in my prime yeah
where he's just like you've got a lot
left to give i don't know why you're
right
but i i really i need it i need therapy
i
i definitely i i push it down and just
talk him today i was like
wow i have not dealt with my [ __ ]
interesting
punishing other people is this [ __ ] uh
work lady family everything
everything it's very hard to deal with
family stuff because i think
your family stuff is like it's a pattern
now it just
is what it is you never you're not like
a 10 year old like hey mom dad we need
to talk about this
yeah we have a pattern that's that's not
really working for me
no you just keep repeating that pattern
until it becomes normal and then
and then you make you base your
relationships on that right right
so these aren't fixed exactly exactly
with my mom instead like is an example
like
i love my mom so i have a great mom but
like i'll do things
like she'll sometimes you know as
entertainers we don't always feel seen i
think like we're similar in that way
we're like
we say shocking things because we didn't
feel seen growing up
sure you know what i mean like that's
like our that's our thing like we don't
feel
like you had an overachieving brother as
well oh yeah and a genius bro literally
a genius yeah
my brother and sister same [ __ ] so it's
like you you do that to stand out you
felt like a black sheep
yes same [ __ ] here it's like it's
patterns so you know with in my case
yeah like i always thought my mom and
she's so proud of me like she i know
she's proud of me but there were times
when she's like you should do you should
write
a shouts and murmurs for the new yorker
or something and i'm just like it's not
the type of comedy i do
and she's like we should do that and
instead of being like you know it hurts
my feelings when you don't see me or
like value me for who i
am i'm just like that's not what i do
it's always do you keep that so you
don't fix the problem
you just keep it [ __ ] going yeah yeah
but do you say that's not what i do or
you just
you just i just get upset and i bottle
it i do the same thing
and that's what i'm trying and that's
just one of like maybe a hundred things
i'm working on
oh you might need a two hour session we
might need a sesh no i mean i i haven't
gone in the whole pan you can do that
for a massage i think you should be able
to do that for therapy
yeah let's make this 90. yes for therapy
you know what jerk me off but
now i'm really confused got jerked off
by an old bearded man but the beauty is
you get to talk to him about it after
and deal with it
but yeah no i'm with you i'm the same
way my mom that's the thing about moms
is they care
they know we like comedy so they that's
her way of being like hey i'm related to
my son
the the murmurs thing which i've never
even heard of shout outs and mermaids
it's a new yorker piece it's like every
thing every article
oh every uh magazine i mean the worst
radio morning team in history
this is shouts and murmurs how are you
doing murmurs
you got that right all right here we go
traffic on lane five all right
but uh yeah so um i'm the same way my
mom will i'll show up at home like for
christmas or thanksgiving and i haven't
seen them in months because uh you know
they live in new orleans
and they'll just go hey here you go and
they'll put a stack of
magazines and newspapers on the table
i'm like what's this and they're like
there's a comedy article in there and
each one of those is a comedy
piece and i'm like okay so
should i sift through all this is gonna
take me three weeks you know this is
like a stack
have they heard of email yeah i'm like
i'm like an old accountant with the i
got a
green visor on you know i'm like i feel
like i got a big file i have to deal
with now
so i'm like going through it and they're
like it's somewhere in there they talk
about joan rivers i'm like oh great
like this is it how about a hug a
conversation or asked me how the show
was or the weekend or the gig or
whatever
they're doing they're and they're
showing love as best they can
yeah and that's the thing that we have
to accept like i'm telling you man like
when you leave therapy and you go back
you feel it the same way you quit
working out and you go to the gym
that first session you're like [ __ ] now
is it in
in person no i'm doing zoom okay cause i
i took off the whole pandemic with alan
because i didn't want to do a rock zoom
yeah sorry i don't know if we're
supposed to say his name but that's all
right
i didn't want to do zoom so i was like
i'll be all right but i got some [ __ ] so
maybe i'll go back and see if he's
willing to go
in person i think you should go back i
mean i remember the first time you went
you called me and i was like holy [ __ ]
there's like a different side of mark
i've never seen this side
no yeah i was doing it would suck
because i remember you called me or like
there's so much i want to say right now
and then uh i think i was about to like
tape something i was about to go on do
some
[ __ ] and then i got off and i was
like i called you back and you're like
and i'm good
i was like i missed the moment mark was
like really being vulnerable i was kind
of interested in it after therapy
it's like doing a set because you have
like 30 minutes of like
after a set you're like i'm superman for
30 minutes and then it fizzles away and
you hate
yourself again and after therapy you're
like i'm healthy and then it goes away
again
i mean yeah we're drinking i went to
therapy and i'm like ah here you're
drinking fireside cocktails
but i gotta say you came in and you you
were kind of glowing
more of a glow than normal i i feel uh
it feels good to work on it like it
feels like that's something
that's you know so yeah all right i'm
making an appointment i gotta get back
it's it's important for me and like look
if i'm not saying it's important for
everybody some people don't need it but
if you but if you feel
that you're needing it look up if your
health insurance uh
covers it also a lot of therapists work
sliding scale like
yes what a [ __ ] cool thing that they
do that yeah i know
i mean so yeah what's your wreck by the
way uh well that's a great one boy that
was heavy stuff and i'm i'm glad you
brought it up but uh
mine was uh i'm at home
i'm flipping through the channels my mom
speaking of mom texted me hey and
whenever she texts i'm like ah
this is gonna be some kind of project i
got a whole thing of my mom she wants to
write a book with me and i'm like
wow you know and she's like she's a big
cook
[ __ ] she's like a foodie [ __ ] so she's
like hey
uh you know you give me a comic and i'll
write a recipe about them and i'm like
all right all right that's kind of fun i
used to like when caroline's did like
the david tell or like the damon wayans
you ordered a cocktail it's kind of a
fun idea
i i guess yeah but i'm like all right no
one's gonna buy it who's gonna buy like
the dave coulier
uh quiche but all right whatever so i'm
like
i like this guy so i'm like groucho mark
she's like all right she comes back
she's like
he's a jewish guy from new york how
about some locks i'm like okay great i
like this
i'm into this that's a whole thing but
whatever
so she texts me i'm like oh it's gonna
be some cooking [ __ ] and she's like uh
the mark twain doc
is on amazon prime it's amazing and i
was like oh wow and i had nothing going
on so i put it on
it's six hours or something or four
hours i watched the whole thing
it was unbelievable i'm gonna watch it
this week i can't wait ken burns
ken burns rules did you watch the
hemingway i'm halfway through that and
that's great
it's incredible yeah but my my sh you
know i steal
cable and it went out uh during that so
i gotta
re-get back i gotta get back on the
horse no no that's pbs it's free
i don't even have cable i know i i don't
i don't have cable what do you use
pbs it's free you just you just go on
youtube oh is that right
or you just type in a hemingway
documentary into google and it comes up
okay yeah all right i was watching on my
you know stolen thing
yeah but all right i'll do that i'll
watch mark twain this week that's a
that's interesting so it's amazing
amazing because like first of all the
guy was killer a killer comic like great
writer
he has some zings that you're like he's
so quick yeah he's she traveled the
world at one point
went to the nile river and uh he goes
how much for a boat on the nile and the
guy goes eight dollars this is like 1890
or whatever he's like
no wonder jesus walked wow you know he
was just zinging and zang and he had
some great lines i wish i could remember
other ones he tried to kill himself at
one point before he made
it try to kill himself right after that
he makes it so it's like
the gun jammed i mean it's it's crazy
[ __ ] and it's
it's pbs and it's ken burns so it's
drawn out but uh
it's not like it's six six parts like
these other ones like world war
ii it's 12 hours but you feel like
you're learning when you watch those
things i mean it's like
ken burns really is incredible
incredible he's a national treasure have
you seen a photo of him
yeah yeah he's tiny he's tiny he's got
weird hair he's a perfect looking
doc guy but he looks like he bakes
cookies and trees in the rest of his
spare time
yeah he does so teeny but i love this
the things he chooses like the way he
goes about the narrative and everything
and it's
it's really touching and the tragedy in
this guy's life
my god it puts all our [ __ ] in
perspective like the things we [ __ ]
about i'm like
the air fryer they sense the wrong color
ah
you know and he's like oh my my kid died
today and then my brother died in the
war and all the it's it's heavy [ __ ]
they smoked 40 cigars a day 40 40.
that's just one of the fun nuggets in
there 40 cigars in a day
i watched it with my girl she was about
to hang herself she was so bored but i
was like
yeah we gotta compromise i was on edge
yeah i loved it
there's a famous story about che guevara
where his doctor said you could only
smoke two
cigars a day for your health and he
started smoking cigars this long
ah that's great it's crazy it's also
funny it's like you're a revolutionary
just let him do whatever he wants
i know he's not gonna live that long
right right he's killed people
um 40 cigars in a day yeah
that is phenomenal and he like tackled
race before everybody
uh he tackled all this [ __ ] he was a big
big atheist guy like because his whole
family dies i don't give too much away
so he's just like
why do we believe in this guy why do we
think he's great and [ __ ] on god
he got a lot of hate but he also was
loved and then towards the end of his
life people kind of caught on to how
genius he was and they would just
fly him out to like england and just to
ask him advice and stuff it's
[ __ ] fascinating damn these days he
would have been like on love line or
something
no it's so crazy he uh yeah he really
was a genius man it's funny i might
always think of jessie pop's
bit about him i remember the when the
whole uh
controversy about how it was n-word jim
oh yeah
and it was the actual n-word and he goes
we was like we should change to n-word
jim and jessie bob's like i got a crazy
idea how about uh
jim jesse pop
underrated comments he's funny check him
out he's got great stuff
yeah uh yeah yeah so that was my wreck
and uh
i i it was four hours and like you you
don't feel it it just
i watched it in two parts loved it damn
heavy stuff
hey hey folks we might be drunk is
brought to you by
upstart do you dread looking at your
credit card
statement every month oh boy do i oh man
all that blow and brothels
we don't blame you but upstart can help
upstart is the fast and easy way to get
a personal loan to pay off your debt
all online oh man i got debt i got cell
phone debt
i got college debt i got uh car
debt i'm insurance now i got a bicycle a
car
i'm all over the road i i got some
apartments i'm swimming in this thing i
need an assistant i don't know what i'm
doing apartments i feel like you lost
the relatability right there
i bought an apartment now i rent one
it's a whole thing it's a nightmare
i would like to buy a studio by the way
so maybe upstart can help because
just like to ride in no like just do
pods sorry matt
but uh you know just to do pods just
like a one rumor oh i thought you meant
like a studio like is used as an office
yeah well we use an office we could we
could do a pod in there we could
shoot videos in there just it'd be nice
to have but
times are tough whether it's paying off
credit cards to consolidating your debt
over half a million people have used
upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment unlike other lenders
upstart
looks at more than just your credit
score like your income
and employment history this means they
can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners just five minutes
for an online rate check
you get approved the same day and
receive funds as fast as one business
day
is debt taking over your life well it's
time to get a fresh start
with upstart tell them how sammy find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
drunk that's upstart.com
drunk don't forget to use our earl earl
url
i'm [ __ ] drunk earl my name is url
to let them know i sent you got to throw
in this disclaimer loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
and now go to upstart.com
drunk nobody got on a peeve okay
people blasting music from their car
[Music]
we all miss dmx it's 6 45 am dude
yeah drives me nuts i grew up with this
in my neighborhood there was a lot of
music blasting and all that and
who is it for are you letting other
people know
is it for are you enjoying being in a
metal box with blaring music i don't get
it
you're you're a graphic tee personality
you need people to know and also you're
forcing your [ __ ]
like how about this we live in a society
where you don't need to impose your
personality
on everyone in a 50-foot radius right
how about just doing your thing i love
quiet people
i love people that keep to themselves
and people who surprise you and people
who are better when you get to know them
people who lead aggressively like that
this is you at your best and it's only
getting [ __ ] worse that's
true you're a rotten onion
[Laughter]
rotten onion what are you my grandpa
this guy's a rotten onion
this guy's an old turnip oh yeah that
was one of the slurs from mark twain's
time
you ride an onion yeah no you're true i
mean you're true you're right it's so
true it's like these guys
have nothing to say they got no
personality so they got to show you with
this
loud music or this crazy neck tattoo
or a mohawk or there's got to be
something instead of having anything
within you or a
cool thought it's got to be this
aggressive over-the-top
showing of hey look at me i got this
i'm loud i hate it it's not talent
it's it's you're right it's like a
talent substitute you're like right i
i want attention i want attention but
all i'm gonna do is be [ __ ] annoying
yeah oh that's it's a real please that's
a big peep and we need women to stop
[ __ ] these guys
ladies yeah don't see the guy drive by
and uh with the blaring dmx and go
this guy he's the one i should be
letting inside me
that'll yeah that'll make him stop
that's that's the only thing stopping
these
douchebags no they'll be they'll be
louder if they don't get laid
they want more attention well that's the
thing i never got about the the banging
with the ladies is like
you know women are always like oh i hate
this guy i hate that guy but the bully
in school
in my high school always had the hottest
girls yeah the the loud guy always got
the hottest girls i'm like
ladies you could you got you guys have
vagina
population control it works both ways i
think confidence goes a long way like
the hot chick was also kind of an
[ __ ] a lot of the time i mean
that's true but at least we love them
and leave them you know we're not dating
them
i just think that's the like like women
were seeking relationships and men were
like but men would date
shitty women i think that i do think it
works both ways
but you're right the bully always had a
hot chick always a hot chick
always yeah and like you know women [ __ ]
on frat guys and wall street guys but
they always
cleaned up i don't know it's interesting
yeah they [ __ ] on them but
deep down they've got money and wall
street guys you can [ __ ] on them but
[ __ ]
madoff's wife didn't know what was going
on
i know right cosby's wife knew what's
going on carmella soprano knew tony
wasn't on the level
exactly not sanitation come on sister he
had
uh cosby's wife that's gotta be a rough
way to go
that's a real 180. oh my god i mean i'm
sure she wasn't thrilled
i'm sure like back like 20 years ago she
wasn't like i love my life
yeah but you know those jell-o chicks
are
still coming in i guess she's still rich
it's gonna be weird to see
that power shift where it went i
remember judd apatow once at the seller
said
we were just like hanging a bunch of
comics and he's like his comedy never
made sense to me because his wife was
always so angry at him over like
nothing and i was like wow that's a
great observation interesting like
on the show no just like in stand up
he'd be like
i'm sorry and it's like you're fighting
over aftershave or some [ __ ] like it
was always like the most minor offense
and she was furious like he was doing
bad [ __ ] right
but you know oh man yeah i can't imagine
the fighting in that house she's like we
never have sex anymore he's like you're
always awake
come on let's do it for me you're always
awake
uh this is really he's like you're
you've never fallen asleep has been a
big problem
yeah yeah during couple therapy she's
always
she drinks a lot of coffee yeah right
right yeah
exactly i touch her she wakes right up
um
it's like rodney's cadence right there
i'll tell you i'm trying to sleep with
my wife
i [ __ ] she wakes right up i'll tell
you i got no respect in this household
no respect
rodney has cosby is a funny funny
character i'm one of the worst serial
rapists of all time i'll tell you but no
one saw it coming
rodney and natural-born killers is one
of the all-time
dark comic turns oh my god i didn't see
that coming
so good watching that movie as a kid
through fingers and i'm like wait
rodney's at this
what the [ __ ] going on rodney
dangerfield's groping his daughter
yeah oh that was wacky that
yeah that was too much like are we gonna
do that in the future
we got some crazy horror movie it's like
is that jim carrey
what's going on is jim carrey [ __ ] a
kid
all right uh hey here's a peep now i got
into it with this gal
um i was with my lady and we're out at a
museum
and i go how much how much is the
tickets you know i'm like getting my
wallet out
and the the woman it was like this young
kind of hipstery girl and she goes
it's uh ten bucks for whatever and five
for seniors
and i go oh well she's a senior you know
pointing to
my lady and she got like she giggled and
this gal's like
wow rude wow and i knew she was trying
to get me on some like
you know whatever pc [ __ ] or whatever
and i'm like well actually there's
nothing wrong with being a senior
so you're rude and she goes wah wah wah
whatever
i'm like no no no whatever you tried to
get me and you wanted me to go
with it so now when i get you you're
you're pulling away
or whatever what if i just whatever you
when when
is the ultimate wet blanket move yeah
she goes wow
whatever like what do you mean whatever
i'm going off your dumb rules
i'm playing your rules i beat you and
now you're mad at me
i hated her that's good yeah that's
you made such a harmless joke and she
and she's just clearly on her high horse
exactly she's on the high horse so i
high horster yeah
i i doubled down i i'd like what do you
call it where did high horse come from
by the way
you think you're better because you're
in a high horse i think by that logic
you think you're better because you're
in a high car hummer
oh same ship was the high horse person
the hummer person
back in the day right right yeah but you
know
a hummer is worse than a porsche
for sure so yeah that's a weird argument
maybe the emperor was on the highest
horse or something
maybe so you she tried to get you and
she just [ __ ] yeah she sounds like
she sucks
i kinged her i don't i put two stacks on
her you know and she was like uh
ah whatever like oh so your whole system
is flawed then
because if if if you were true to
yourself you'd go
ah okay you're right but you don't
believe any of your own [ __ ] that's
why it bugged me
if you're gonna play that [ __ ] with a
stranger you gotta play it you gotta
play it
you gotta comment you can't just be like
i win yes yes
she just wanted to win that's what bugs
me about that whole thing is like
you just want the scalp you want the
kill you want the gotcha
but you don't actually want to play by
the rules everyone wants the credit no
one wants to do the work i mean look at
look at when you post a video now
everyone
writes first you want credit for being
on your phone more than me
great point that's what you want first
is the thing
i'm first you should take a break yeah
you shouldn't be first
first is a negative first should be
embarrassing you ever you ever look at
your instagram stories
you're like i wonder how many views this
got and you see and it's up for like 30
seconds you buy oh it's a new one
and you see and you're like oh that's
weird that they saw it first first is
not a good thing
right first is like showing up an hour
early to a party
oh yes so true yeah that's not a
an accomplishment you're not impressive
you're the loser here and you're letting
us know you're the loser us know you
loser at the same time you think you're
the winner
yeah i know first all caps eight
exclamations
i'll tell you these first people they
got the smallest [ __ ] i've ever seen
you know
but that's like going to a party and
going first imagine that guy
it's insane first is [ __ ] yeah
it's the worst first is the worst first
is the worst you heard it here
first okay uh now this is another pet
peeve and this has nothing to do with
people
this is just my own [ __ ]
you see this a lot in in cities in new
york or wherever
the address first of all i hate i had a
i hate an address that's hard to find
you know you're like okay there's a
business here what is that that's the
phone number okay that's the
whatever i need the number of the street
i'm on 14th street
what is the address number and then you
look and it says
3800 broadway but broadway's around the
corner
but they still want to be considered on
broadway so the business
wraps around yeah the corner i used to
deliver pizza
and this would drive me up the [ __ ]
wall just put the address out give me a
clear number
make it simple and then sometimes it's
like 49 and a half
or uh you know this is uh this side of
the street's 46 and that side's 47 but
there is no 47. we
went straight to the 49ers it's an ego
thing you want to be part of a cooler
avenue
right and and you've made it confusing
you've made it confusing i'm just trying
to drop off the pizza here folks
no it drives me crazy and it makes it
much harder to you know
for for delivery people makes it much
harder for ubers it makes
making everyone's life harder i know so
just [ __ ] cut it out
and be yourself that's what the problem
is you're trying to be a different
address than you actually are
i want it 46 48 50
52. why why does it have to be weird
it's trans of addresses
yeah yeah okay like i'll play along for
trans like
that's your life but this is an actual
this is the thing where i'm like no this
is a thing this isn't a person
so just be your [ __ ] be what it is
yeah and you're not the [ __ ] bat cave
like why are you so hard to find i want
this to be a you know this is a deli or
a pizza shop or
or a coffee shop or a house like i'm i'm
trying to give you packages or
or pizza whatever brutal yeah yeah i
i'm with you 100 oh the address you want
is always
mysteriously gone you're like okay
there's 58 there's 60.
what the hell where's 59 okay 59 should
be over there but it jumps up to 71.
like ah dress also
yeah also if you live in one of those
places you have to just be like every
time like no no it's
here yes so it's annoying too right this
building is great because they put a big
piece of paper taped to the wall you see
that just says the address i'm like
thank you
i love it yeah i love hey let's let's
treat us as if we're dumb as [ __ ]
yeah and let's make this easy for
everyone well we got the gps now which i
think
is is up the dumbness because you're
like oh the computer will figure it out
dude i remember doing the road with joe
list and he was
driving off a map oh yeah oh yeah a map
yeah i delivered pizza at 17 and i had
map quest printouts i had an almanac
that question is different than an
actual map though map
question at least is like you're going
i'm going to that
right right yeah where a map is like
this is i i go two inches
right that's [ __ ] insane yeah yeah no
good
no good at least this thing goes you
have arrived and you're like all right
so i'm in the area
but do you have the audio on when you do
it oh yeah really
i like the audio damn when i'm driving
in la
i need it because you don't want to just
be like you rent a car in l.a
every time i'm an uber guy i just can't
i can't trust you
every now and then you get like the be
there in 12 minutes you're like oh [ __ ]
it's a 12-minute ride now i'm adding the
full double the ride
i get stressed out because sometimes
they'll they'll chat with you and i'm
just like
if i'm there i'm doing like podcasts all
day or something and i'm like oh i don't
have it man
yeah i got nothing like not even like
like i'm not even trying to be rude i'm
like i just don't have it
i get it i get it yeah you know you want
to be like here just
let me play my segura episode really
loud talk to this guy
this is entertaining i got nothing left
in me
i'm so with you yeah that people don't
realize that because they're like
well you can't talk you're some kind of
big shot you're like i'm out
i'm tired it's like i hit the gym and
now you want me to do curls
i was in cleveland i was just like the
guy thank god he just talked but didn't
expect me to talk back
yeah you know morning flight i was
exhausted yeah um
i was in a car with a couple oh sorry
sorry i cut you off oh no he was just
giving me the whole run down to
cleveland
but it was like kind of charming he was
like clearly loved it and i was like i
kind of like it i kind of like how went
to cleveland he is and it's making me
more into cleveland
i don't mind that and those guys will
just go you know
if they just want to go i can it's like
a museum thing like you just go
i'll sit back and watch this but if they
need
engagement i'm kind of like oh dude i
woke up at 4am and i'm i got nothing
yeah oh totally and i just want to close
my eyes and and daydream about you know
my ex
but it's so true that uh
that they they'll just go but the
problem with communicating and
conversation is the reacting yeah that's
really what wears you out it's not
thinking of stuff to say it's not
trying to be charming it's like uh-huh
oh is that right get out
that's what wears you out well you'll
listen to a podcast they look at us
the way we look at a crowd we're not
giving them enough energy
right they're kind of like guess i'm
bombing yeah
it's a [ __ ] wall it's an uber when
you put it like that i feel guilty then
for sure
yeah interesting it's a show we didn't
sign up for
aha it's like the paper tickets
well we used to well they signed up
though that's true that's true
we used to do comedy ambush
ambusher yes people would be eating
dinner and we'd have to just go up and
be like
well you guys suck and they're like it's
a first date like you know what i mean
like they weren't they weren't happy
that's true good point this manhattan is
not too shabby
no it's hitting the spot it's hard not
to we got
i got four shows i got four too where
are you
uh the stand 13th step
brooklyn city winery i'm um
gotham the seller city winery the seller
oh that's a good night it's a good night
you're on the west side
the whole night real good night i'll
tell you that's what it's all about
gotta get some new jokes to hit i know
me too man
oh i had some about the uh the uh the
uber damn it i lost it oh i got it back
i can't believe i got it back uh
i was in a car with a bunch of comics
and i'm a backseat guy
everybody fights over shotgun i don't
want shotgun
too much pressure in shotgun there's
like weird
radio stuff also you do more reacting in
shotgun because the driver is talking
you gotta go oh yeah get out of here
whatever
back seat check the phone every now and
then you can kind of zone out you can
come in when you want with the convo i
love
backseat well you're chill type a alpha
dudes
always want shotguns too they can
control the radio oh maybe that's it i
don't want any control
i'm good yeah i'm fine with it and i'm
saying i'm with you
uh i also i'm also a very
nervous like you know i back i have a
bad back always and i'm always like i'm
in the front seat i want to make sure
they have enough room in the back you
know
yeah so it's hard for me to enjoy the
front oh
i just prefer i'm with you i prefer low
pressure low press
it's the same with the grill guy you
know you go to the barbecue he's like
whoa whoa you're flipping those wrong
let me do the grill get out of the way i
got it
you're like great you do it i don't want
to [ __ ] pay attention to pads
you get to do the grill you're tony
soprano you're the guy that ever wants
to [ __ ] kill
yeah i'm just a dude eating free [ __ ]
meat yeah exactly
exactly i'm laid back and and also who
are these psychos that have to have this
right music i don't like the song i'm
like i hate all the music you guys pick
but i'm fine with it
i'm just in the back hanging out i'll
tell you a bar i want to get drunk in a
bar that plays sinatra
all right i don't want to be in a
[ __ ] loud bar i hate loud bars i hate
it all we have is our personality
you know that's it that's it i never i
never like walked up to a woman she was
like yes it was always like i always
kind of [ __ ]
won her over over time a good line or
something
and although i was at a bar with you
once and a woman approached you pretty
quickly and i really i was
i was a little jealous and impressed i
was like man
i think it was the height you were the
tallest guy in the bar and this gal i've
seen women do that to you
what approach you no oh [ __ ] off
i don't think so maybe my aunt fake
humility i don't think i've been
approached maybe by a woman's like hey
you stole my soap or something
we've seen the shirt radio pics we've
seen the pull-ups
i walk into a bar people go hey can you
send these drinks to table nine
i don't think any there's no lady
approaching me at a bar
if there is let me know the bar i know
you you tie your shoes different than
most people i noticed
i don't i i do the knot i'm one and done
people spend six years of their life
tying shoes and you just
you just do that like that but that you
get enough ankle support i sound like
i'm 97 years old here
is that that is that comfortable for you
yeah yeah it's i like a slip-on
interesting i don't want the uh it's
tight enough to where it stays on the
foot but also loose enough i can slip on
interesting yeah you don't see a lot of
people that that tying
uh situation oh is that right is that a
me only
i i don't i mean it's not like i pay a
ton of attention but i saw it i don't
see that normally
all right i'll take it yeah i thought
everybody did that
i i don't i'm doing just the regular the
loop-de-loop
yeah the loop-de-loop then they get
loose now they're all off on the on the
on broadway getting every [ __ ] germ
on them and they need time now you get
the germs that you have i don't know
as long as it's the real broadway and
that's some [ __ ] half address
yeah that we're off broadway kind of
and it's like i took a car i took the
corner
looking at the addresses i find one
still broadway
come on the worst the worst what uh
should we do a bid yeah let's do a bit i
got a few in the works here and like
man i another shout out to cleveland
hilarity just like man weekends like
that remind you
what we've been missing out on like holy
[ __ ] hell yeah great city i was there
for the nfl draft too which was like
complete craziness like oh
right but uh yeah the crowds just rocked
a lot of we might be drunk people
got two we might be drawing people on
the subway right over here that's a good
sign i love it i love that
so uh you know uh that's all i want out
of life is to be recognized in my in the
city i live in
yeah but not too much you can just until
enjoy your life yeah
but uh you know um
yeah i one i had was and i don't know if
this here it's kind of like a two-parter
but i
i don't know where to go i don't know
and the problem with this pocket is
we're always drunk so i never know
yeah if i've said this before but one is
you ever own a dating app and you see a
woman she just posts a picture of her as
a kid
and you're just like who is that for a
[ __ ] disappointed pedophile
right like right he just shows up on the
date like you should really use more
recent picks
this is a little rude you know so that
kind of got a lot it needs a little more
but then i did hold like kind of a
tangent when i was like you know what i
like about pedophiles and that gets kind
of a laugh because they don't expect
that line but yeah
i like about pedophiles is uh they never
complain at a joke
you never meet a pedophile who stands up
like you've gone too far
right right there's something scared to
complain exactly yeah there's something
nice about a group that doesn't want to
identify yeah
everyone's about being identified not me
identity politics they're like no thank
you i went out of that
i don't want to identify as this yeah
that's funny
that's a great angle but i think you got
a lot with the kid pick
yeah who's that for first of all
even if you are a pedophile you're not
on tinder because
it's just a bunch of like regular legal
aged women
and then if you the way most people
swipe like a lot of people are like
yes yes yes pedophile is like ugh no no
yeah
all day long like finally a kid pic but
uh
it's yeah two as a normal heterosexual
male who likes
uh you know legal aged women who's that
for
the whole the whole point of the picture
is like let me see what i'm working with
here let's be honest yeah i don't want
to see potential
yeah i mean if anything this is what a
man wants show me a picture of you
in 30 years right i'd like to see where
we're going
right more than what's been interesting
you know
yeah let's see let's see a future like
that that face app thing that makes you
look old
yeah that's doable yeah throw me yeah
that's
that's doable or throw me your mom in
there throw your mom or your grandma
john fish had a bit like this i think
john fish it a bit about i want to see
your mom
i think he had a bit like that i think
we were too close to him oh that's good
he's funny john fish is a [ __ ] great
kind of underrated comment check him out
john fisher he has an album called uh he
has friends
yes killer killer one joke after the
next no he's
i love his stuff oh that's good that's
good yeah
i think the mom thinks too close i think
there's something like that all right um
also there's another angle with the uh
the girl who has her friends in the
photo
and the friends are better looking right
that's another weird one where you're
like
all right i'd like to say hello to to
this one
how how do i get to her yeah is that you
mean
it's almost like a mystery i think it's
another john fisher i think fishing a
joke i'm the one on the right and he
goes who's the one on the left
i don't think i could top that i think i
think he cracked that one too damn
fish johnny fish man all right all right
underrated comedian
and uh give him a goog yes there you go
funny guy great album hope he's doing
all right oh he had a kid
yeah he's a kid good for him it's funny
hope he's you know right he's happier
than any of us
yeah he's got a family that's right
we're drunk on [ __ ] tuesday afternoon
mark
you think you think you're worried about
him that's my heaven
all right fish damn i'm trying to think
of another angle but i don't want to
step on old uh
fish cakes there 20 minutes later that's
actually
fish's uh closer you just stepped on
john fish damn all right uh no i think
we got plenty more and i got more ideas
i mean we if we got time i mean
you you do a bit you do a bit of yours
all right
that's funny though that's so true with
the kid pick um
nobody cares about what you look like as
a kid a lot of people do that
i don't get it but all right whatever
it's it's very arrogant it's kind of
like
look how cute i was that's what it is
look how cute i was yeah
uh all right it's hard to be a not cute
kid most kids are cute it's true yeah
show me an ugly kid then i'll be
interested yeah all right
that's a real pedophile by the way
by the way uh a lot of kids are cute in
hollywood and then get ugly
yeah that kid who was in jerry maguire
there was nobody cuter than that's like
shredded now though
oh is he i think so oh okay oh that kid
was adorable adorable
jesus i don't even like kids and i was
like this kid's great
yeah and then a lot of what makes a kid
cute can make you kind of awkward
looking as an adult
that's true like a big head like haley
joel osmond i was going to say him neck
he got weird looking but he's
i mean he's he's still a great actor
though like silicon valley but yeah as a
kid you're like adorable kid
yeah it's hard it's hard to it's tough
it's tough
yeah you grow up how you grow up uh
i'd like to see ugly kid good-looking
adult i wonder if there's a
i feel like that's a lot of models yeah
they always say i was awkward i
was awkward i was so awkward and then
you're like all right and then you see a
picture like you were [ __ ] hot
yeah yeah yeah you were pretty you had
you had braces but
i can get over that i was so that's a
hot girl thing i'm so
weird how and they have no follow-up
yeah
i'm just a weird person why because you
like like popcorn with like
something when instead of butter it's
like always like hey do you think that
makes you [ __ ] weird
i like cold pizza i'm weird shut up we
all like gold pizza that you're not
super feed 110 pounds yeah and you've
got big tits somehow
somehow i'm weird i'm so weird
and then i just i go i'm working on this
pedophile a bit and i go i gotta get out
of here
i thought you were weird where's the
weirdness um
all right this bit i've been trying to
crack this joke for 20 years i can't do
it i might have run it by you before but
i'm just so
that's the problem with drinking like i
know but i'm just so
into the i think there's something here
and i have a lot of these bits where i
couldn't crack it for six months and
then i found we're detectives brother
yes these are cold cases yes cold case
files
i'm reopening the file let's do it all
right there was a girl on a well
no uh
so uh i bought a car
and my girlfriend is like ah i'm sick of
the car i'm all you're done with the car
i hate the car
i think you like the car more than you
like me yeah and the joke is it's not
that i like it more it's just easier to
understand
a car has a dashboard with nothing but
dials and gauges
that let you know what's going on women
are very vague
women are very silent treatmenty you
know you got to figure it out
cars just tell you out of gas e
overheated
hot the engine of a car is never caught
on fire and the dashboard
says i'm fine like a car will never lie
to you about how it's feeling
good point yeah so that gets a laugh the
uh women don't tell you when they're
in an empty they just pick a fight with
you yes exactly i wish women had
like a little dial where you're like
[ __ ] i gotta make sure she eats before
noon
or something like that oh yeah yeah then
i have a joke like
and i've tried every angle all over the
place like
if women had gage they would say i'm
fine whatever you think and i don't care
but imagine if a car was like does this
take unleaded or diesel
i don't care now it's broken so like
i know there's something here but i
can't and the point is if a car was like
that
it would be unsafe so what do you think
i'm dating
that's true women have no warning a car
at least will be like hey the airbags
are out
you know women are like i'm just going
to kill you randomly in your sleep yeah
uh maybe that's something yeah i don't
know i can't and then i have a whole
thing about if your car is quiet
everything's going great with your car
like wow it's running perfectly that
works well
makes you guess right
this is a relationship you should just
tell me but we have to guess
a car is something that like it would
never be like
the dodge you have to guess how i'm
feeling yeah
you know yeah right right you figure it
out
you should know you have no no cars like
you should know what i'm i'm needing
i don't know do you need gas you should
know you got to tell me i don't know
your tank
but yeah then i have another thing but
if a car is quiet it's
running great but if a woman is quiet
you're in deep [ __ ] well done
yeah good comparison that that does okay
but this feels like a big
it's a big big but i'm i'm getting
chuckles here and there nothing really
is sticking maybe that's the end you're
one of the best at sticking with bits
and cracking them i think
i think uh cars and women is fun
because we i think the problem is men
think women are like cars so we treat
you like
i need to fix this i need to work on
this but women don't want to be fixed
they want to be heard
right you know uh which is like tough
with a car you know if a car if the
tire is going right and leaking
and you go i gotta patch this tire the
tire doesn't go just listen
well women will sometimes say like i'm
cold say take my jacket
no i just wanted to tell you i was cold
yes exactly no
device does that we look at things as
very you know
women are so they have so much nuance
and cars are just like blah blah right
so yeah there's something interesting
about that where you're comparing like
we're used to just trying to fix
yeah exactly and women are really hard
to fix
yes they want to be understood more than
fixed and that's where i came up with
this angle which i thought was something
but it's getting
zero uh all right i'm gonna tell the
joke doctor
that's not me women we treat women like
cars but they're not like cars they're
horses
which already sounds bad but stay with
me
a horse gets you from a to b just like a
car but it has feelings it has emotions
it has needs you know and you know
we'd rather ride it without a saddle or
whatever it is yeah
obviously that's silly but um you know
women are more like horses because they
you gotta tend to them
instead of fixing you can't just get a
wrench and a horse
obviously you know you gotta fix it or
you gotta talk to it you gotta
emote you gotta relate which is why
women like horses you gotta feed it
you gotta feed it you gotta take care of
it it's a very expensive uh you gotta
house it
you know now it's getting weirdly
taken care of me but you see what i'm
saying and i thought the horse angle
would save the bit but it's not
there's something to this women are
and then the heart the horse car
compared i mean there's this is a bigger
bit
yeah women are like horses because you
have to take care of them
they need to pet them and comb the hair
they want shoes
there's a lot here shoes line hit i have
a try i just thought there's something
there
okay um they need shoes are very
important
shoes are very important that's a good
line and it sounds best i'm comparing
women to a big smelly
muscular animal but it's part of a
bigger idea it's not i'm not just trying
to insult
the ladies here i'm saying you know
they're they're like a car but with
feelings instead of an engine yeah
that's the pause they're like a car with
feelings
they're like a horse that's he pause you
see that they're like a horse
oh yeah that's interesting yeah so
that's where i'm stuck
but give me give me a month and i'll
maybe i'll but it's gonna take a lot of
bombing with it
and this is the part of comedy that is
hard but also why it's great
well yeah you stick with it you get that
reward exactly like a horse
the difference is the horse knows where
you're going
women always like where are we going
where is this relationship going
where is this i'm trying to just yeah
because the car is like where are we
going i'm
i'm wherever you want to go i'm down you
tell me
you know and the woman's like i want
some say
which is kind of like a horse you know i
want a plan yeah
yeah interesting
a plan is important yeah also i have a
stick that i
i hit a woman in the ass with all right
that's something is it yeah
also you slap a woman in the ass right
right
yes aha
i i'm thought this is too much i was
thinking like
horses
like in war i always think like when
things get tough you're like [ __ ] take
her
you know that's not it that's not it
right right
yeah you want to ride it uh
yeah they're beautiful creatures yeah
exactly
the uh majestic
yeah it's it's interesting but that's
that's why i because
just the fact that you're noodling with
this so much tells me there's something
here
you know i like i like your mind because
it's always to me it's
if you think there's something funny
there you know every once in a while we
both have [ __ ] we're like yeah i'm not
really feeling it right
i think usually you have big ideas that
can be kind of
play with because you know i love your
bits so i'm thinking of like
the women women yeah you think they're
like cars but they're really like horses
yeah yeah i don't want to put too much
pressure on no no no it's
something to think about it is the shoes
the butt slapping
there's a lot here and also when i was a
kid every girl had like a
have a had a binder with a horse on it
they loved horses women
like horses they do and a boy had a
ferrari
or a lamborghini or whatever was that in
the cars i wasn't really either as a kid
but
i saw a lot like i'd go to my friend's
house you have a big car on his wall you
know
funny i see like seinfeld or leno and
i'm like that's so not what i would
spend my money on if i had that kind of
money yeah yeah
i'd rather a big house and a you know
cool apartment
for sure but yeah i get it so
i don't know i think there's something
there but uh i'll keep noodling
and you tell us what you think i got a
lot of feedback on the uh pedophile
and food joke about bananas and avocados
and all that so
the folks are helping they're they're
tweeting they're they're writing in they
give you your peeves your whole thing
i think i'm missing anything oh yeah did
we go did we cover everything no i was
just thinking about the bit
oh okay yeah it's a heavy duty
this is this is a big bit heavy duty
which is what horses do
yeah you don't want to see either of
them [ __ ]
there we go all right all right
something um
horses
shoes horses sound like women when you
piss them off
i don't know they'll buck you off yeah
you do something right if you try to put
in her ass they're like
uh stallion seabiscuit
secretariat ah jockey
yeah that's the only difference between
horses and women horses like small guys
ah maybe that's another would be better
for a horse
what's that you that'd be better for a
horse right right
exactly yeah you think a small guy ever
gets on top of a horse
you know trying to [ __ ] it they're like
at least he's small yeah
yeah i don't want a woman to peg me
maybe i don't want a horse to [ __ ] me i
don't know who knows there's a lot here
well we're
we're noodling folks this is this is the
writing process but uh
yeah i feel like how what are we at matt
are we good yeah i think we got
a full up here make sure to email us
we're gonna do your patreon questions
sign up for the patreon at patreon.com
we might be drunk pod
email us at we might be drunkpod.com uh
even we might be drunkpod
gmail.com sorry the booze is hitting me
uh make sure to rate and review us
follow the the we might be drunk
instagram page follow me follow mark
look for us on the road uh i will be in
uh
utah and arlington virginia this month
and uh yeah wise guys
and uh the draft house we already got
seven shows in arlington i hope we add
more even i can't wait hell yeah wait
what you got mark
i got all kinds of fun dates i'm in
spokane going back to the
p n w as they say
classic club great club i mean uh
hartford coming up tickets are horrible
so come on out for connecticut
i don't sell well in canada i don't
either because it's right here you know
it's too close
yeah portland oregon helium that's gonna
be a hot one syracuse
toledo funny bone houston improv philly
helium buffalo
uh all kinds of dating i just added
dayden is fun man i just added
um yeah that's a fun town i just added
some more added um
albany oh me too july 4th and 5th
i got uh atlantic city
the 11th and 12th of july plug that i've
got
tampa in june 18th these are june not
july no i said july june
12 11th and 12th atlantic city tampa uh
17th through 19th side splitters raleigh
uh the 25th to the 27th of july june i
mean
[ __ ] i can't speak anymore i'm glad
we're ending this this time he hasn't
eaten
uh i'm in atlanta yeah oh and send us
some names if you think of a rye
name yeah i love call back dude i like
call back with i like call back with a
grungy looking cat yeah you know beat up
looking cat with maybe a smoke in its
mouth something funny
yeah or a uh or the cockfight is kind of
fun too cockfight is fun
i like call back with an old rotary
phone on top of it too
that could be fun yeah so send us some
names
and uh yeah patreon peeves rex i got a
lot of good bands
from uh i mentioned sales which is a
cool band and so a lot of people sent me
a bunch of [ __ ] so yeah keep
keep emailing and we will read them on
the patreon tell a friend
see us live spread the love i get so
many messages about oscar peters
peterson how much you guys are loving
oscar peterson so that makes me happy
when
rex seemed to resonate with you guys
yeah hell yeah i'm loving it oh some
people message me bill evans as well who
i love i love bill evans uh
so if you like jazz check bill evans out
as well
oh you'll love him uh keep listening to
the pod man i mean i'm having fun i
think we're rolling we're rolling go to
therapy
tell a friend and uh yeah keep on
drinking
or not drinking uh again guys thank you
so much for listening we're having such
a great time and shout out to gotham
studios
on 38th street for having us hell yeah
we love it here we love matt we love the
spot
uh you might have given away the address
there but hey
who's counting thanks a lot